[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous je suis keziah
vasconcelos et je suis ravi d'être ici
pour échanger avec vous sur le mouvement
perpétuel
après avoir réalisé des études
d'ingénieur en btp et un master
entrepreneurs j'ai décidé de créer mon
entreprise avec mon associé lui si la
main nous nous sommes donné pour mission
de sauver notre planète en réduisant la
production mondiale de nos déchets
lorsque j'entends mouvement perpétuel
je pense aux rubans de mots bus ce ruban
qui a la particularité de n'avoir qu'une
seule face qu'un seul côté un insecte
peu le parcourir à l'infini et ce
concept est à l'origine du logo
universel du recyclage qui a pour but de
transformer nos déchets en ressources
utiles en parlant de déchets savez vous
quel est le plus gros producteurs de
déchets en france le btp exactement avec
247 millions de tonnes de déchets qui
sont générés chaque année cela
représente
c'est l'équivalent de 25 mille tour
eiffel et à l'échelle nationale ces deux
tiers de la production pour le second
oeuvre ses 10 millions de tonnes de
déchets qui sont générés chaque année
par le bâtiment
c'est énorme et c'est pourquoi la
nouvelle loi de transition énergétique
sur la croissance verte impose que 70%
de ces déchets soient valorisés d'ici
2020 pas revalorisé on entend recyclés
ou réemployer beau défi puisque
aujourd'hui on atteint seulement 35%
autre question
savez vous que s'est il passé le 2 août
2010 est celle overshoot day c'est la
date à laquelle nous avons consommé
toutes les ressources que la terre peut
produire en une année en d'autres termes
nous vivons à crédit si l'humanité
vivait comme un français il faudrait
trois planètes 5 pour un américain
et à l'échelle mondiale cela représente
un peu plus d'une planète et demie je
continue planter le décor 30 milliards
de tonnes de sable qui sont consommés
pour la fabrication du béton des
kilomètres de plages disparaissent
chaque année le sable et la deuxième
ressource naturelle la plus consommée
après l'eau alors la question qu'on se
pose c'est comment faire de la
croissance infinie sur une serre aux
ressources limitées
la réponse tient en deux mots économie
circulaire l'économie circulaire qui
vise à changer de paradigme par rapport
à l'économie dites linéaire en limitant
le gaspillage de nos ressources et
l'impact environnemental
c'est changer notre façon de consommer
l'économie circulaire s'appuie sur la
règle des 3 r réduire réutiliser et
recycler et bien que ce concept était
inventée dans les années 70 définies
dans les années 70 il existe depuis la
nuit des temps
au 2e siècle avant jésus-christ l'on
retrouve les premières formes de papier
recyclé en chine
fabriqué à partir de ressources
naturelles des corses de mûrier de
filets de pêche et ce papier pouvait
être réutilisés jusqu'à sept fois avant
d'y introduire une fibre 9 l'économie
circulaire est ancrée en l'humanité et
l'automobile l'a bien compris puisque
95% des voitures de la masse volumique
des voitures sont valorisés en fin de
vie recycler ou réemployer et les
garagistes ont l'obligation de proposer
une pièce de réemploi
à toutes fins de voitures et le réemploi
dans le
tp c'est une pratique ancestrale dès
l'antiquité les murailles aurélienne à
rome sont fabriqués à partir de briques
de récupération au moyen âge la
cathédrale saint-jean dans les
soubassements sont fabriqués à partir de
blocs de marbre d'une ancienne
constructions romaines la seconde guerre
mondiale varsovie est détruite à 85 % et
les bétons vont être réutilisés pour de
nouvelles constructions et en sous
couche routière est aujourd'hui que
serait le réemploi sur un chantier qui
parmi vous a déjà travaillé sur un
chantier avec du réemploi alors imaginer
voici julien conducteur de travaux sur
un chantier de réhabilitation lourde et
chaque jour ils jettent des tonnes et
des tonnes de matériaux et jeter tous
ces matériaux ça lui coûte cher
donc d'un côté on à julien conducteur
travaux sur un chantier de
réhabilitation et de l'autre côté on à
andré artisans constructeurs de maisons
individuelles et chaque jour il passe un
temps fou à trouver le matériau le plus
économique et écologique possible et ils
sont nombreux à avoir les mêmes
problèmes et si les matériaux de julien
issus de déconstruction pouvait servir à
la construction d'andré et les bénéfices
sont nombreux
d'abord il permet de construire durable
et de réduire la production de déchets
mais il existe également des bénéfices
économiques par exemple prenez l'exemple
de 500 m² de polystyrène destinés à être
jetés en l'air et employant cela permet
d'économiser le coût de la mène le
transport le traitement et de générer un
revenu supplémentaire par la vente côté
acquéreurs c'est bien sûr réduire le
bilan carbone c'est augmenter le champ
des possibles de construction
architecturale c'est construire
autrement avec moins et c'est économiser
le coût des matériaux en utilisant de la
matière dit première secondaire alors si
c'est si simple pourquoi nous
n'atteignons pas les objectifs fixés par
la loi de transition énergétique et bien
les frais
a soulevé par l'ademe sont les suivants
le premier c'est l'assurance le secteur
du btp est un secteur très réglementé
c'est construire avec des matériaux
d'occasion qui porte la responsabilité
c'est la question de coût est-ce que
construire avec des matériaux de
réemploi et compétitif par rapport à des
matériaux neufs en y intégrant les coûts
cachés
et puis la logistique les questions de
stockage de déconstruction est justement
de nombreux acteurs trouvent des
solutions pour lever ces freins
c'est le cas en belgique où ils ont
développé un nouveau savoir faire pour
passer d'une démolition à une
déconstruction sélective et la belgique
a un maillage de ressourcerie qui permet
donc de stocker ces matériaux et c'est
justement sur chantier sur un chantier
de réhabilitation lourde
j'ai fait le constat de la quantité de
matériaux qui partaient à la benne y
compris des matériaux neufs en fin de
chantier des surplus de commandes alors
qu'en face on construisait ont
réhabilité un hôtel des bureaux dont ces
matériaux pouvait potentiellement servir
et trouver une seconde vie et donc c'est
pourquoi avec mon associé lui si l'amant
nous avons décidé de monter notre
entreprise pour répondre à ce problème
alors on a commencé par faire une étude
terrain interrogé tous les acteurs
concernés
et puis la question qui se posait
c'était comment faire connecter
l'offre et la demande y at il vraiment
une appétence pour construire avec des
matériaux d'occasions on a commencé il
ya un an et demi
et puis on a commencé à recevoir nos
premiers appels de clients de vendeurs
et donc pour les mettre en relation nous
avons créé la place de marché digital
dédié au réemploi de matériaux de
construction concrètement nous mettons
en relation des vendeurs avec des
repreneurs
l'objectif est d'identifier de nouvelles
ressources de les cartographier et de
les mettre à disposition de manière
instantanée
comment ça marche prenons l'exemple d'un
conducteur travaux sur un chantier de
réhabilitation avec des portes de all
destinés à être jetés
c'est très simple
pour trouver une alternative à la belle
il les met en ligne sur la plate forme
entre quelques caractéristiques il
valait cartographier car cela permet
d'interagir dans un rayon de 20 km et de
promouvoir les filières locales et il va
entrer une date d'enlèvement qui
correspond à la date limite à laquelle
le matériau devrait être mise à la
baisse comme les yaourts les matériaux
ont une fin de vie une date de
péremption qu'on leur impose alors
qu'ils sont encore en bon état et
pourrait trouver preneur et les exemples
de réemploi sont nombreux donc nous on
est très terrain le bien-fondé exemple
concret donc par exemple sur un chantier
de réhabilitation d'une gare parisienne
des panneaux acoustiques devait être
jeté
ils ont été mises en ligne sur la
plateforme et en moins d'une semaine on
trouvait un repreneur et aujourd'hui ils
ornent les murs d'une célèbre entreprise
alors on est tout jeune on a commencé on
a déposé la société il ya moins d'un an
aujourd'hui on travaille sur une
soixantaine de chantier c'est une
centaine d' annonce des centaines de
matériaux qui ont trouvé une seconde vie
et ce sont des centaines de rencontres
puisque l'objectif c'est vraiment
d'aligner tous les maillons de la chaîne
afin de faire perdurer promouvoir
l'économie circulaire notre coeur de
métier c'est d'introduire l'économie
circulaire sur chantier mais le réemploi
peut également être détourné son nom de
son usage pour fabriquer du mobilier
design
par exemple ce fauteuil qui a été
réalisé à partir de talais de chantier
de chutes de tissus et d'assez ou encore
quand l'art s'empare du réemploi en
plein coeur de la forêt de fontainebleau
cette sculpture le cyclope de gentili
qui a mis plus de vingt ans avant d'être
réalisée et qui a été construite à
partir justement de matériaux de
chantier qui n'avait plus d'usagers et
aujourd'hui le réemploi c'est concret
c'est possible le pavillon circulaire
sur la place de l'hôtel de ville a été
content
et à partir de fortes de menuiserie d'un
immeuble parisien destine à être démolis
de caillebotis récupérer de laine de
roche
c'était un projet expérimental qui était
destiné à rester deux mois
finalement il est resté quatre ans avant
d'être mis aux enchères
les bénéfices du réemploi et de
l'économie circulaire
selon une étude pourrait permettre un
gain de 465 milliards d'euros
d'économies sur le coût des matériaux
alors la valeur économique de l'économie
circulaire est démontrée
mais quelle est la véritable valeur de
nos ressources de notre planète
alors je crois en la force du digital
je crois en la force du bim le btp
pilier de notre économie est en
mouvement perpétuel
il tend vers une économie circulaire et
six sur vos chantiers vous pouviez
permettre de faire de nos déchets
d'aujourd'hui nos ressources de demain
il ne tient qu'à chacun d'entre nous
d'agir
merci
[Applaudissements]